Oh
hello this is - again I am now in Oslo
back in Norway I am now going to play a
game to test out the Magna meter the new
feature of the app that shows shows you
how you're doing devaluation I have to
say this is the first time I'm going to
test it but it has been tested before so
don't be worried so I'm going to play
against a younger version of myself
Magnus 9 both because that is very
convenient for me and because there will
be lots of jumps in evaluation so
probably anyway so you will see how the
Magna meter works so I'm white that was
lucky and we just unleashed the mega
meter so far both sides have made normal
moves looks like we're gonna play we're
gonna leave English tomato meter see I
haven't done this before upgrade now so
so far it's showing all equal which is
not too surprising since we're in a
theoretical position here well I really
played like this when I was 9 uh I did
not know that so this is a theoretical
lines I knew quite a lot of theoretical
lines when I was 9 years old
but not this one
so for all of the those of my colleagues
out there watching the game I don't
really want to show you all of my prep
in this line so fortunately -9 played
something else so I don't have to do
that ha
so now -9 is doing something really
risky grabbing a pawn without any
development and it's up to me to try and
punish him so it's not immediately
obvious to me how I'm going to do that
maybe minus 9 just came up with a more
or less brilliant novelty so
well now I think -9 is going a step too
far so taking the pawn now I can take it
back but then there will be 2 minor
pieces and 2 points against the rook
which is usually more or less equal
trade but here my pieces are active in
its middle game so it will be favorable
for me I think if I insert the Queen
check instead I will be a whole piece up
I really hope I'm right so now I'm going
to exchange now I'm not going to take
his Knight when I'm going to take his
Bishop first and then his Knight so he
moves his Knight away now I think I'm
going to have some fun and insert a
little trick right there seems that now
minus 9 will not only have problems with
being a piece down but you will also
come under an attack now if it takes
with the rook you will be mated so that
was not a real sacrifice now let's let's
continue in in gambit style
on the other hand let's not just going
to take it easy consolidate way the
piece up so now I'm winning back one of
the points I was done and now probably
one more
now let's see I think there might be no
huh thought I might be able to win a
roof but unfortunately he can put the
rook in between there's I'm just going
to play something simple instead but now
on the other hand I think I think I
miscalculated so now I'll have to
instead of winning Riddler I will have
to go for the boring option change all
the pieces and hopefully I will be able
to show some of you how to check mate
with the Queen and and Bishop because
when you're playing against Magnus at a
lower level then then it's sometimes not
so difficult to capture all of his
pieces but giving checkmate is not
always that easy so you need to know
some of the techniques you can see the
arrow has been firmly on my side for a
while and now it's all over there in the
in the winning area
so - nine stops one of my pawns but
fortunately I have not one but two
others now we can't make up his mind
which one to stop so instead he goes for
the other but now I already have a new
queen so now I'm going to to checkmate
very soon and this is a good way to
check to checkmate a lone black King now
if I had you know what just for for fun
I think I will give up all of my pieces
except the king and the Queen just to
show you quickly how you can checkmate
the black king when it's trapped in the
corner
now that was cheeky he's forcing me to
is forcing me to do something else
because now if I were to Queen the pond
then it will be stalemate so I am not
very interested in that so let's give up
the other Queen first so now driving the
King towards the corner now we have the
same position as before but but I've
given up all of my pieces except the
king and the Queen now the king is
trapped to two squares in the corner and
the only thing I need to do is bring the
King over and checkmate
but it's important not to take away all
the squares from the King until you give
a check because then it will be
stalemate so I'm just bringing the King
over and now that the king is here it's
checkmate okay